what causes the weather to change this
is a question every pilot should know
the answer to if we want to be safe when
we fly so in this video i'm going to go
over the basics of what you need to know
as a private pilot
our planet is surrounded by multiple
layers of gases and these help support
life on earth by absorbing heat and
light from the sun they also allow water
to be recycled on the planet
these layers of gases are called the
atmosphere our atmosphere is made of
many gases but mostly nitrogen and
oxygen and also a little bit of water
vapor which we'll talk a little bit more
about here in a little bit we divide our
atmosphere into four distinct layers
because they're made of different stuff
and they have different characteristics
but today i'm mainly going to focus on
the troposphere because that's where the
majority of weather takes place now at
the poles the troposphere starts at the
surface and goes up somewhere between 4
and 12 miles over the equator it only
goes up to about 48 000 feet and above
that there's a thin boundary layer
between the troposphere and the
stratosphere called the tropopause and
this boundary layer traps most moisture
and weather inside of the troposphere
and that's why there's really not a need
to study the other layers inside the
troposphere for every thousand feet of
altitude that you gain the temperature
decreases about two degrees celsius
now oddly enough even though they're
invisible all these gases in our
atmosphere have weight in fact our
atmosphere is 350 miles high and if you
were to weigh a one square inch column
of air the whole height of our
atmosphere it would weigh 14.7 pounds
and as you increase your altitude
there's less air on top of that other
air so it would actually weigh less
and this is why air pressure decreases
as altitude increases to measure air
pressure we used to use mercurial
barometers and at sea level on the
average day the air pressure would push
the mercury up to 29.92
inches and this is where we get that
standard pressure setting today we use
aneroid barometers to do that instead
they're not quite as accurate but
they're a lot more readily available and
they're probably a little bit safer now
as i mentioned a second ago our standard
air pressure at sea level is 29.92
inches of mercury but in some countries
they measure pressure in millibars
instead if you're lucky enough to be on
the metric system the standard pressure
in that case is one thousand thirteen
point two millibars anyways for every
thousand feet of altitude that you gain
the air pressure decreases about one
inch of mercury or roughly 34 millibars
now let's go back and talk about the
atmosphere for just a little bit
as you probably already know the sun is
responsible for the majority of our
weather and it's mainly because the
earth's surface is heated by the sun
unevenly when the earth's surface is
heated this causes the air near the
surface to also be heated and when this
happens the air molecules in this air
spread apart and the warm air gets less
dense that causes the warm air to rise
and it gets replaced by cooler air as it
does
if you haven't already started flying
this is one of the first things you're
going to notice if you fly on a sunny
afternoon you're going to feel those
updrafts push your plane around quite a
bit especially if you're somewhat close
to the ground and some types of ground
heat up more quickly than others and
water heats up a lot less quickly than
the ground and because of that those
updrafts won't be nearly as bad over
water so now what we get is a bunch of
air circulating in our atmosphere that
warm air rises and the cooler air rushes
in to replace it and that's what causes
our atmosphere to be in constant motion
now as i just kind of touched on the sun
heats the ground unevenly but it also
heats the entire earth unevenly in fact
the equator takes most of the direct
sunlight and the poles receive very
little
because of that if the earth didn't
rotate this is what the majority of that
airflow might look like for my friends
who believe in a globe of this shape
this is probably what that circulation
looks like for them
sorry i can't help myself i just find
flat earth stuff funny anyways we're
going to focus on the baller theory
because that's the way the faa explains
it in the pilot's handbook of
aeronautical knowledge at least for now
anyways so as we mentioned if the earth
didn't rotate the flow of the warm and
cool air would look something like this
but because the earth rotates the
coriolis force forces these airflow
patterns to look more like this
let's spend just a minute talking about
the coriolis force and i want to do that
because to me it seems like the coriolis
force works backwards and i feel like if
i don't explain this very well this next
part's not going to make very much sense
to do that let's take a look at the
earth from the top of the globe from up
here the earth rotates counterclockwise
on its axis as you can see from up here
everything out here by the equator has
to travel a longer distance than
anything closer to the poles because of
that everything out here closer to the
equator travels just a little bit faster
now let's say i'm standing here in
mexico and i could throw a baseball all
the way to the north pole not only would
the ball be traveling north but it would
also be traveling in the same direction
as the rotation of the earth but as the
ball moves north the earth beneath it
actually moves slower and because of
that as it travels north it also moves
to the east and that's because it was
already moving east but now it's moving
east faster than the ground beneath it
and that's the coriolis force in a
nutshell and just like my baseball when
that warm air at the equator rises it
travels north and when it does it's
slowly deflected to the east and it only
makes it up about a third of the way
before the air is completely moving east
and this is actually why the upper level
winds in the continental us are usually
out of the west while all this is
happening this air begins to cool down
this causes the air to become more dense
and when it does it sinks back down to
the surface once it does it moves back
to the south to take the place of the
warm air in the southern hemisphere the
air moves in the opposite direction and
really similar cycles occur between the
30th and the 60th parallel and up at the
poles now things do get a little bit
more complicated when we start talking
about the seasons and the fact that the
continents heat up more quickly than the
oceans do we'll talk a little bit more
about those here in just a minute but
you should be aware that friction caused
by the topography of the earth also
comes into play and as you can see from
this picture this can be anything from
mountains hills rocks and trees to
man-made features like buildings or even
hangars and all this stuff can cause
changes in the wind direction wind speed
and also cause gusty winds okay so now
we know that when the sun heats the
ground the air above it also gets heated
and when the temperature changes so does
the air pressure because those air
molecules spread apart not only is the
air pressure lower now but there's also
more room for water vapor in fact for
every 20 degrees increase in temperature
the amount of water vapor that the air
can hold actually doubles and water
vapor is lighter than air so this can
make the warm air rise even more quickly
we'll talk about this more in just a
minute but for now just realize that
with all these areas of different
temperature we also get areas of
different air pressure and because of
that now we have areas of high pressure
and areas of low pressure with that in
mind air always moves from areas of high
pressure to areas of low pressure think
of a glass of water if i pour it out on
the ground it's going to move to the
lowest spots in that area but oddly
enough the air doesn't move in a
straight line to these low pressure
areas because of the coriolis force
remember high pressure air is cooler air
that is sinking back to the surface so
in the northern hemisphere the northern
parts of the sinking air are deflected
to the east and any air that moves to
the south is deflected to the west so
because of that air actually moves
around the high pressure system in a
clockwise motion areas of low pressure
are those areas where the warm air is
rising so as that air rises it also
deflects to the east and this causes a
counterclockwise movement of that air
but the closer the air is to the surface
the straighter the air travels to that
low pressure area because of the
friction on the ground so now you're
probably wondering why you need to know
this as a pilot and the first reason is
that this can be really helpful when
you're planning a flight because it can
help you pick a flight path where the
winds are more favorable for example if
i know that i'm flying near a high
pressure system would i want to fly
north or south of it well in this
example we want to fly south of it
because we're flying westbound this will
give us a tailwind which will actually
increase our ground speed and that's
going to help us get to our destination
even faster now we can get an idea of
how strong these winds are one of two
ways let's pull out a couple weather
charts from aviationweather.gov
now if you have four flight you can
actually look at these charts in there
as well for flight makes everything so
easy these days because almost
everything you need for flight is in one
spot but if you don't have four flight
this is where you should be checking the
weather because this is probably the
best weather source available for pilots
first things first let's take a look at
this prog chart this one is an analysis
of the surface conditions as you can see
we've got some high pressure areas here
and some low pressure areas so we know
roughly which direction the wind will be
moving at altitude but notice these
lines surrounding the pressure systems
these lines are called isobars and these
represent how much the pressure is
changing in these areas this is
important to you because the closer
these isobars are together the windier
it is in these areas because of that i
know that if i'm flying here in north
dakota i should have less wind than
normal and it should be from the south
down here in northeast oklahoma it's
going to be super windy and the wind
should be coming from the northeast
the other way we can see the wind
conditions are on these weather charts
that depict wind flags this particular
chart is a surface weather chart now to
me these little wind flags work
backwards the side with the flag is the
side where the wind is coming from
short bars represent five knots of wind
long bars represent ten and the triangle
represents fifty and you have to add all
these up to get your total wind speed in
this area so as you can see here we have
south winds at 15 knots in north dakota
as i mentioned before
it looks like winds are almost straight
out of the north at 20 knots in oklahoma
and that's probably because there's a
cold front that just passed to the
southeast otherwise that wind should
have been more out of the northeast
we'll talk more about fronts in a minute
but before we do i just want to mention
something else about these pressure
systems that i think is important when
you think of high pressure areas
remember these as areas of cooler drier
air that drop back down to the surface
this drier heavier air is much more
stable so you're typically going to see
good weather in these areas now think of
those low pressure areas as that warm
air that rises it can hold more moisture
so it brings the water vapor up with it
which causes clouds rains and all kinds
of other bad weather and this is going
to come back into play in just a minute
but for now let's talk about fronts okay
so we've already discussed how the sun
heats the different types of ground
unevenly and how water and land heat
differently as well
and this causes air circulation in a lot
of areas across the globe but there are
also a lot of areas on our planet where
the surrounding ground in water is very
similar and these stagnant areas occur
in polar regions tropical oceans and dry
deserts so these areas don't circulate
that much these become stagnant areas of
either cool air or warm air
the air in these areas build over time
and they eventually push their way into
other regions these are what we call air
masses as these air masses move forward
there's a boundary layer that forms
between the air mass and the air in
front of them and this boundary of
changing air is called a front the front
at the beginning of a warm air mass is
called a warm front and the boundary at
the beginning of a cold air mass is
called a cold front if we take a look at
our weather charts we can see the
different types of fronts moving into
our area warm fronts are depicted as
these red hot blisters while cold fronts
are depicted as these cold blue icicles
now on occasion you will see two other
types of fronts these are occluded
fronts and stationary fronts and we'll
talk more about those here in just a
minute let's start by talking about warm
fronts first
warm fronts are very slow and only move
about 10 to 25 miles an hour
the warm air tries to push into the
cooler air but because it's lighter the
warm air is also pushed up above the
cooler air in the process
now as i mentioned earlier warm air can
hold more water vapor so warm fronts
will typically bring a lot of humidity
into the area
as this warm air rises the temperature
drops and when that happens you get
condensation let's stop right here for a
second and go into a little bit more
detail about this because once you
understand a few basic things you'll
understand what kind of weather you can
expect when a front passes now if you
remember from earlier the air in our
atmosphere actually has water vapor in
it and the warmer it is the more water
vapor the air can hold this ratio of
water vapor in the air to how much it
can hold is called relative humidity and
dew point is a specific temperature that
we can use to determine our relative
humidity let's say the dew point is 14
degrees celsius when that air is cooled
to a temperature of 14 degrees the air
becomes completely saturated and it
can't hold any more moisture and because
of that moisture begins to form in the
air and this can take the form of dew
frost fog clouds rain or snow now as we
already mentioned several times when air
is heated it rises and in the beginning
of the video we also mentioned that the
temperature drops two degrees celsius
for every thousand feet of altitude that
you gain and as that warm air rises it
also expands because that air at higher
altitudes is less dense and as that warm
air expands this also causes the
temperature to drop and how quickly the
temperature drops depends mainly on how
much moisture is in the air as it rises
if the air is completely dry it'll cool
off about three degrees celsius every
thousand feet of altitude that it goes
up and if there's any moisture in the
air it cools off even slower than that
that means that as that warm air rises
it cools and gets closer to its dew
point that's why clouds typically form
high in the sky with that in mind we can
actually estimate the height of the
clouds if we know our temperature and
dew point
so now we know that as that warm air is
lifted it cools at a certain rate
depending on how much moisture is in the
air in addition to that as that warm air
is cooled it can't hold as much water
vapor either so the dew point decreases
as well
but it doesn't decrease quite as quickly
as the temperature does
so as altitude increases temperature and
dew point get closer together or
converge and the rate at which it does
this is 2.5 degrees celsius or 4.4
degrees fahrenheit and remember anytime
you see the temperature equal to dew
point that's where you're going to see
the clouds rain fog and all kinds of
other moisture so now that we know that
we can take the temperature and subtract
the dew point and then you can actually
divide that by the convergence rate of
2.5 degrees celsius then all we have to
do is multiply that times a thousand
feet and that's where the base of our
clouds should be here's another example
let's say our temperature is 22 degrees
celsius and our dew point is 18. 22
minus 18 is 4 and 4 divided by our
convergence rate of 2.5 is 1.6 and 1.6
times a thousand is 1 600. so in this
example the base of our clouds start at
1600 agl and this can change slightly
depending on how stable the area is in
that area stability is the atmosphere's
ability to resist vertical motion when
the air is stable if there's a minor
disturbance in temperature and pressure
these small disturbances will get
smaller and smaller until they
completely disappear when the atmosphere
is not stable these small disturbances
will get bigger and bigger and that warm
air will rise faster and faster
temperature and moisture are the biggest
contributors to atmosphere stability the
hotter the area is close to the ground
the faster it will rise and the hotter
the air the more water vapor it can hold
and because water vapor is actually
lighter than air this can cause warm air
to rise up even faster if it's got a lot
of moisture in it and the faster that
air moves upward the more violent the
weather can get this is why
thunderstorms and other convective
weather is so common in hot moist areas
and the more moisture that is added to
the air the more unstable this air gets
and with that in mind moisture can be
added to the air in a few different ways
now as you probably already know there
are three forms of water in our
atmosphere solid liquid and gas and they
can easily change forms to any other
form when a heat exchange takes place
these are the different types of changes
that can take place
evaporation sublimation condensation
deposition melting or freezing but to
understand today's concept the only two
you need to be familiar with is
evaporation and sublimation these are
the only two ways that water vapor can
be added to the atmosphere
sublimation is when the solid form of
water changes directly into a vapor this
process is a little less common than
evaporation because it requires a drop
in air pressure as well as an increase
in temperature
when i think of sublimation i think of
dry ice now dry ice isn't really the
solid form of water
but the process that happens when you
heat it up is really similar evaporation
on the other hand is the primary process
that water vapor is added to the air and
the hotter it is the more quickly water
evaporates and the more quickly it
evaporates the more moisture is in the
air and that makes the air even less
stable in addition to all that sometimes
the temperature doesn't always drop
exactly 2 degrees celsius every thousand
feet if the temperature drops faster
than that the warm air can rise even
more quickly and once again this would
mean that air is even less stable in
these areas if the air temperature
changes more slowly than 2 degrees for
every thousand feet this would make the
atmosphere more resistant to upward or
downward movement in fact it's also
possible for the air to get warmer with
altitude and this is called the
temperature inversion when this happens
any moisture in the air can get trapped
close to the surface this can mean low
clouds fog haze smoke and other types of
poor visibility situations and this is
where a lot of students get confused a
stable atmosphere does not necessarily
mean good weather it means that you
don't have a lot of upward and downward
movement of air in these areas and the
stability of the air in conjunction with
the temperature and moisture are what
determines what types of clouds you see
now clouds are primarily broken up into
four categories
low clouds middle clouds high clouds and
clouds expand all of these because of
vertical development low clouds can be
anything from fog stratus stratocumulus
and nimbo stratus these form near the
surface and extend to about 6500 feet
agl and these are a particular
importance to you because these are
going to affect your ability to fly
under visual flight rules here's some
examples of some low clouds stratus
clouds are typically flat sheet like
clouds
cumulus clouds are the puffy friendly
looking clouds so these stratocumulus
are just a mix of the two and anytime
you see nimbo or nimbus that just means
it's a rain cloud or it has rain in it
and once again it's not uncommon to see
any of these low type clouds when the
air is stable and that includes those
nimbo stratus clouds that have light
steady rain and that's because that
stable air resists vertical motion which
keeps those clouds close to the ground
they're probably going to try to trip
you up on the test with that question
next we have middle clouds these
typically form between 6 500 and 20 000
feet agl typically these come in two
types altostratus and altocumulus in
altostratus clouds you'll often find
areas of turbulence and even areas of
moderate icing
altocumulus clouds may also contain
areas of light turbulence and light
icing and these things are important to
remember when you start working on your
instrument rating and you start flying
through clouds altocumulus clouds are
usually formed when altostratus clouds
break up
high clouds usually only form in stable
air these form above twenty thousand
feet agl up here you'll find serostratus
cereal cumulus and plain old cirrus
these are these wispy ones then last but
not least we have clouds with extensive
vertical development the bases of these
typically form in the low to middle
range and these contain lots of warm
moist unstable air which rises very
quickly as we said before this is what
we call convection in addition to these
updrafts air that cools is brought back
down along with air that's cool by
precipitation
this can cause downdrafts in excess of
3000 feet per minute and this is one of
the most dangerous parts of a
thunderstorm but in addition to that
thunderstorms can produce hail lightning
tornadoes heavy rain and all kinds of
scary stuff that i don't want to fly in
so now that you have a good
understanding of that let's go back to
talking about fronts
and we left off talking about warm
fronts and how they bring a lot of warm
moist air into the area and when any
front moves into an area the weather you
get depends on how stable the air in
that area was before that front moved in
remember warm air is less stable because
warm air rises and it holds more
moisture which makes it even less stable
now in almost all atmospheric conditions
this is typically the type of cloud
conditions that you'll see with an
approaching warm front before it hits
you'll usually see these flat stratus
type clouds which roughly follow the
bottom edge of that warm air and the
weather you get right here at the base
of the warm front depends on the
stability of the air and if the air is
unstable which is typical of the summer
months you could see thunderstorms
develop in these areas with that in mind
no matter how stable the air is you can
still expect to see drizzle or steady
light rain in these areas
visibility might be bad right before the
front passes but once it does it can
often get really clear outside because
that warm air can pick up a lot of
contaminants and carry them away from
the surface
also as the front passes expect the wind
to change directions and right before
the front passes the air pressure can
rise slightly and once it does the
pressure should go back down
next we have the cold front these are
large air masses that are made of colder
denser and more stable air
these commonly come from large areas of
cold air in the arctic and polar regions
now even though the colder air is more
stable than the warm air cold fronts
move a lot faster than warm fronts and
they typically move about 25 to 30 miles
an hour okay so we already know the air
inside of a cold front is more dense
than the warm air in front of it and
this causes the cold air to push that
unstable warm air forward and up which
causes that lifting motion
and that means that air right here is
less stable and once again the type of
weather that you get when a cold front
passes depends on the stability of the
air that was already there so during the
summer when the air is hotter and more
moist it's very common to see
thunderstorms along the leading edge of
a cold front and cold fronts can be
hundreds of miles long and this can
cause huge lines of thunderstorms at the
beginning of the cold front these are
called squall lines right before the
cold front passes you'll usually notice
a drop in air pressure because that warm
air is being pushed up you'll also find
gusty winds coming from all different
directions and poor visibility and right
before that cold front passes is when
you can expect the worst kind of weather
there can be anything from heavy rain
showers to severe thunderstorms with
lightning hail and severe turbulence
it's also not uncommon for cold fronts
to produce tornadoes then once the front
passes you'll usually see cooler
temperatures higher air pressure and
winds typically flowing the same
direction the front is moving
these winds usually help visibility
improve as the front moves farther ahead
now there is a possibility for a mixture
of these two fronts to occur if two
opposing air masses meet each other and
they're somewhat equal in strength
you'll get something called a stationary
front
stationary fronts can cause bad weather
for days and the weather you get is
usually a mix between the weather you
see in a cold front and a warm front you
can identify a stationary front on a
weather chart by the opposing cold and
warm front symbols an occluded front on
the other hand is what you get when a
cold front catches up with a warm front
this is indicated on a weather chart by
these purple lines with a mix of warm
and cold front symbols with an occluded
front in the beginning you can expect
the same weather as a warm front and
this weather is immediately followed by
the same weather that you would expect
from a cold front typically the cold
front plows its way in and pushes that
warm air from the warm front up
and pushes the cool air that was there
already straight ahead when it's able to
push that cool air forward without any
problems this is called a cold front
occlusion but if for some reason that
air that was already there is cooler
than the air in the advancing cold front
this can cause some extremely violent
weather in this case the cold front air
can no longer push the cooler air
forward so instead it's pushed up over
the warm front air this is what we call
a warm front occlusion
with this cooler air being pushed above
the warm front air this can cause
extremely unstable lapse rates and this
air can be so unstable that the weather
you get can be even worse than what you
might see in a normal cold front so the
big thing i want you to remember today
is that stability is a key factor in
what type of weather you'll have the
hotter it is and the more moisture there
is the less stable the air will be
and that's why thunderstorms are a lot
more common during the summer months and
remember stability doesn't necessarily
mean that you won't have clouds or
precipitation in stable air it's not
uncommon to have stratiform clouds and
light steady precipitation you can even
have poor visibility because that
moisture is held closer to the surface
it's that unstable air and those
unstable lap rates that cause rapidly
rising air which can cause all kinds of
violent crazy weather
and this is great information to know
before you go fly that piper cherokee or
cessna 172. i hope you learned something
today but don't quit studying just
because this video is over here's
another great video to help keep you on
the right track towards your goal as a
private pilot